hello, antonio, while I'm eating, it's very good and how about you, you
want to be an artist tomorrow because this
morning I had a glass of milk and a
piece of toast with extra virgin olive oil
as you normally go to school because
I normally go to school on foot
but  if the weather is bad only a few
days with the car how long does it take to
get to school because it
takes about 15 minutes on foot to get to
school and by car more or less the same
what is your mentality when you get to
school every  days well when he arrives
at school I arrive curious to
know what my students are going to surprise me with
that day a man
something you like from the town where
your school is located well in the town
where the school is located  what
I like most is the people the people of
this town are very good people they
have this favorite movie star
the cinema is that I like it a lot then
I have many favorite stars but
well just like that  probably
meryl streep clint eastwood and since i'm a
geek from the era of thanks for
i also really like harrison ford
do you have your favorite singer or band
my favorite band is directors but
i also really like bon jovi
i also really like as a singer david bowie
who  he is your hero
because my hero is there are many but perhaps
newton i consider to be one of
the greatest scientists of all
time in fact my dog is called newto
what
lace would you love to visit well proba
ly japan japan briti
h columbia in canada come
ith me  that I'm going to show you where I
work
what was your favorite subject in
school
because in school my
favorite subjects were math and physics
and which was the one you liked the least
in Latin in Latin or I didn't like it at all
what kind of student was it in  school well
at school
I was not a very good student because I
worked very little
what is your favorite food in
the school cafeteria well my food  da
favorite in the school cafeteria
was because we no longer have to bring aunts
due to lack of space it has become
a classroom it was the potato omelette that
víctor and rafael made here now they usually
leave school because
we leave school on the  three in the afternoon a
little later as it is some days
because he is doing zamani and you have
a little more left he
usually continues working when you get
home because when he gets home he just
keeps working for many hours in
fact this is where he ran to the
exams  I prepare the classes I edit the
videos that I upload to my echo channel come down
with me and I'm going to show you where he recorded
the videos
what you do to relax
because to relax what I like the most
is walking in the countryside
and another thing that I really like and that  it is
very relaxing it is also walking with the
beach think that where I live in the
province of cadiz we have some
incredible beaches rates for example and then
if I remember correctly we have 6 park  It is
natural and right here where I live
I am between 2
natural parks, the Alcornocales
Natural Park and the Grazalema Natural Park, so
to walk around the countryside I have a lot
of incredible places
what are your favorite hobbies
outside of teaching, well,
my  favorite pastime
with reading I really like reading
I also really like the movies
in fact I am a movie buff I watch a lot of movies
and the votes I love the photos
what is your achievement that you are most
proud of as a teacher
possibly the achievement that
I am most proud of  I feel is that I have
shown my students that we can
help others very easily with very little
effort
if you could write a motivational quote
on your blackboard what would it be because if
motivational quotes I can think of many but
there is a song by john lennon in which
in  at one point he says
maybe I'm a dreamer but I'm not the
only one
I would like my students not to
lose sight of the fact that they have to dream and
there are  that dreaming all the time about what you
want to achieve when you dream the most is
essential to motivate yourself
what is the most important advice you would
give to your students because the
most important advice I would give my
students is that the important things
that are achieved in  life is
practically always achieved with effort with
work then if they want their
dreams to come true they should work and
dedicate themselves to what they like
finally because you became a
teacher well I became the teacher
because since I was little
I explained to my  classmates
when I was 13 or 14 years old in high school
too and I liked it I felt very good
and then when I finished my degree I
started working as a teacher and I loved it
after that many years ago and
I'm still here because I love it
well with this  antonio we have
finished we thank you and
see you soon very well it was delighted to
see you see you
later see you later